i think kind of ushering him in with
that song that is so special to us in
such an intimate way
was um yeah a first and i got emotional
just seeing him across the stage
knowing that he's worked so hard to get
to where he is and i get to share that
moment with him
i'm really proud of where my body is
right now even if it is like
several pounds heavier it's like i did
something that half the population
can't do so i think that's pretty bad
um yeah that's kind of how i
came to that epiphany myself and i was
like i'm gonna share this i'm really
proud of where i am in my journey and
i'm not like a stick but i love the fact
that i've got curves now and
it proves that i i did something really
amazing and uh wonderful with my life
and
yeah so that's kind of where i was at
and whether you've had a kid or not it's
like
who cares just enjoy working out if you
want to do that enjoy
eating rich hearty foods like i did last
night like i was eating short ribs
before the acm awards
do it all like who cares mickey just
completely slayed it tonight i can't
even imagine with a newborn
how much goes into hosting a show of
this magnitude and she pulled it off
with
such aplomb and grace and
uh just wit i i would be so awkward up
there i already am in general and she
just is such a pro
and also her performance left me in
tears
so she just killed it it was it was sort
of the mickey show